is America moving forward or backward
they were the behemoths of the twenty
twelve election cycle american
crossroads and crossroads gps spent
hundreds of millions of dollars american
crossroads is responsible for the
content of this advertising and they
lost 2013 brought deep soul-searching
meet steven law the group's president
CEO loss spent the year listening the
donors who watched the group come up
empty they'd like to feel like they're
investing in something that's going to
actually have a material impact on the
direction of the country that there's a
possibility to win elections funding was
slow at first but a favorable electoral
map and a refined donor pitches started
to take hold its bird million-dollar
checks from hedge fund billionaire paul
singer and former univision chairman
jerry / in co the money enabled
crossroads to deploy new sharper
strategy before this year it stayed out
of primaries but in 2012 that opened the
way for weaker candidates if it's a
legitimate rape who lost in the general
crossroads took no chances in 2014
striking an agreement with other
establishment groups to spend big in
primaries to ensure the right candidate
moved on north carolina was a big test
their crossroad spent 1.6 million
dollars to help Tom Tillis win his
primary there was joint polling joint
communication so that was it was a level
of coordination that we hope to continue
into the fall Karl forties the group's
political director he's worked a
streamlined coordination between groups
a key component of the Tillis primary
win take a look at the last five weeks
of TV spending in the race American
Crossroads supplemented to Tillis
campaigns push in a big way for a month
then the US Chamber took the final week
stepping and right when crossroads
finished its by now it's illegal for the
groups to communicate directly with
campaigns but there are other ways like
using the media to broadcast where and
when they would spend twenty million
dollars on fall TV advertising which
crossroads did in early July you're
seeing all the other groups now start to
kind of layer in and that's that's a
coordinated effort another component of
that effort is crossroads own internal
State polling on the ground intelligence
operations all led by forty who then
turns that into targeted ads Alaska
Arkansas
Louisiana North Carolina Iowa Montana we
are going to look at what's going on
there right now how much help we think
the candidate needs what their
fundraising looks like when we think
they can go on the air with primary
season coming to an end the real test
looms in the general election law knows
his donors are looking for returns our
donors expect us to be like a private
equity fund that invests in politics we
make good decisions based on a careful
look at the data and a lot of ground
research